the fascinating journey of green
onions Farm Vibes life have you ever
thought that a small green onion could
hold so many fascinating details from
lush green fields to the family dining
tape the Journey of a green onion might
surprise you
join us as we explore the secrets of
cultivation unique recipes and discover
a whole new culinary world with green
onions in the video
[Music]
below green onion also known as
scallions or spring onions are an
essential ingredient in many dishes
around the world especially in East
Asian
[Music]
Cuisine in recent years countries like
China Japan and South Korea have emerged
as major exporters of green onions
making significant contributions to the
global supply chain China alone accounts
for over 70% of the the world's green
onion production with thousands of
hectares dedicated to cultivating this
versatile
[Music]
crop with such large scale production
efficient farming methods play a crucial
role in meeting the growing demand TI
cultivation process from seed to harvest
green onions are easy to grow and adapt
well to various farming techniques from
traditional soil planting to indoor
cultivation and modern farming methods
in this video we will introduce you to
the method of growing organic green
onions in a controlled
environment an advanced method that
tightly controls environmental factors
to ensure optimal quality and yield the
Journey of the green onion begins with
preparing nutrient-rich
soil Farmers carefully mix fertilizers
ensuring a balanced supply of minerals
and nutrients essential for optimal
growth after preparing the soil it is
transferred to specialized Machinery to
automate the seed sewing process these
machines place the soil and green onion
seeds into trays with Precision ensuring
even distribution for uniform early
growth of the plants after planting the
seeds the trays are arranged in a
tightly controlled environment where
temperature and humidity are carefully
monitored crucial factors to ensure the
successful germination of the
seeds the green onions will Sprout
within just a few days in these ideal
conditions regular watering helps keep
the soil moist without water logging
ensuring the roots of the plants grow
healthy as the green onions grow they
are moved to another area of the
facility where they receive ample
sunlight and the appropriate temperature
to support further
development this stage is crucial as the
plants will undergo photosynthesis
and benefit from the stable climate
promoting Healthy
Growth this is the delicate
balance between light water and
nutrients that allows the green onions
to grow without stress after about 70
days the green onions will mature with
tall vibrant green leaves
at this stage they are transferred to
floating trays for hydroponic
cultivation benefits of hydroponics in
hydroponic farming organic nutrients are
pumped into the water allowing plants to
continue growing without the need for
soil this method not only saves space
but is also environmentally friendly as
it allows for precise control of
nutrients and reduces Water waste 10
days after transitioning to the
hydroponic stage the green onions will
reach full maturity and be ready for
Harvest workers carefully pull each
plant out of the hydroponic trays and
use specialized Machinery to trim any
excess Roots ensuring a clean and
uniform Harvest next the green onions
are sorted and categorized by size and
quality with only the best onions
selected for packaging and
processing to ensure cleanliness the
green onions are thoroughly washed under
an advanced water system removing any
dirt and impurities ensuring they meet
food safety standards before
distribution from Farm to Table green
onion kimchi P kimchi after harvesting
and cleaning green onions can be used in
a variety of ways one of the most
popular methods especially in South
Korea is making P kimchi green onion
kimchi this unique kimchi has a rich
spicy and aromatic flavor created from
fresh green onions chili powder garlic
and other spices the process begins by
neatly arranging the fresh green onions
in layers to ensure the spices are
evenly absorbed a special spice mixture
comprising chili powder garlic ginger
and fish sauce is added creating a rich
and balanced flavor next the green
onions are carefully coated with the
spice mixture a step that requires
Precision to ensure uniformity once
mixed the green onions are packed into
specialized containers to undergo
natural fermentation which can last from
several days days to weeks depending on
temperature and humidity conditions
during
fermentation the flavors meld together
creating a rich and flavorful side dish
that pairs well with many traditional
Korean meals the final product P kimchi
is a bold spicy and aromatic Delight
that enhances any meal especially Korean
barbecue when served with grilled pork
or beef its distinct flavors Elevate the
dining experience making each bite even
more delicious and satisfying the global
demand for green
[Music]
onions green onions are not only a
staple in Korean cuisine but are also
widely used worldwide
as more people recognize their
nutritional benefits Global demand
continues to rise packed with vitamins a
c and k as well as antioxidants green
onions are a nutritious choice for
health conscious consumers they support
digestion boost the immune system and
promote heart health making them an
essential part of many healthy diets
join the farm Vibes Life Community
thank you for watching this video we
hope you've gained fascinating insights
into the Journey of green onions from
farming to their culinary significance
now we'd love to hear from you have you
ever tried growing green onions at home
share your experience in the comments
below don't forget to like subscribe and
hit the notification Bell so you won't
miss our upcoming agricultural
documentaries see you next time on Farm
Vibes
[Music]
life hello from Farm Vibes life Welcome
to the next episode of our agricultural
documentary Series today we will dive
into the fascinating world of date
harvesting focusing on the use of modern
shaking machines and Advanced Techniques
in date
packaging join us as we follow the
entire journey of the Phoenix
dactal also known as the date palm this
flowering plant belongs to the Palm
family
aracas and is cultivated for its
delicious sweet fruit although its exact
origin remains a mystery due due to
centuries of cultivation it is believed
to have originated in the regions
surrounding Iraq date palms are now
cultivated
worldwide and have naturally adapted to
many tropical and subtropical
regions this process begins with
selecting high quality seeds or cuttings
from mature
trees offshoots are preferred because
they retain the genetic characteristics
of the parent tree these offshoots are
carefully planted in nutrient
well-prepared
soil Sandy LOM soil is ideal as it's
good drainage as crucial for healthy
root development dat Palms thrive in hot
dry climates with plenty of sunlight
they thrive in temperatures ranging from
77° to 104 de
25 de to 40 di irrigation is essential
especially during the early years
Farmers often rely on drip irrigation
systems to provide consistent moisture
while conserving water in Spring date
palms Bloom producing flower clusters
called inflorescences from the leaf
axils there are male and female date
palms male trees produce small fragrant
white flowers while female trees have
larger cream colored
[Music]
flowers pollination is key to fruit
production in nature the wind carries
pollen from male flowers to female
flowers however to increase yield and
ensure a Bountiful Harvest Farmers often
resort to hand pollination
they collect pollen from male flowers
and gently sprinkle it onto female
flowers enhancing the chances of
successful
fertilization one of the most exciting
Innovations in modern agriculture is the
use of shaking machines for date
harvesting previously harvesting
required workers to climb tall palm
trees and pick the fruit by hand but now
thanks to these machines the process is
faster and less labor
intensive after harvesting the dates are
transported to processing facilities for
cleaning sorting and
packaging the cleaning process involves
washing the dates to remove dirt and
debris next they are sorted by size
color and quality premium dates are then
packaged using Modern Machinery ensuring
optimal
conditions packaging often involves
vacuum sealing or modified atmosphere
packaging or metp to extend shelf life
an essential step for dates destined for
export markets ensuring they remain
fresh during
transportation in
20123 global date exports reached a new
high with Egypt Saudi Arabia and Iran
dominating the market recent statistics
show that Egypt exported over 200,000
tons generating significant Revenue
Saudi Arabia and Iran closely followed
each shipping approximately
150,000
tons Advanced farming methods and modern
technology and date cultivation and
processing play a crucial role in
meeting the growing Global
demand countries have invested resources
in research and development to increase
yield enhance quality and promote
sustainability a persistent challenge is
the demand for skilled
labor while shaking machines and
Technology have reduced manual labor
trained individuals are still needed to
operate equipment and manage Farms
efficiently training programs and skill
building initiatives play a crucial role
in bridging this Gap governments and
agricultural agencies play a significant
role in supporting the date palm
industry policies that promote research
provide financial support and facilitate
access to global markets are crucial for
its growth the future of date farming is
bright driven by continuous advancements
in technology and
techniques researchers are developing
new date palm varieties with better pest
resistance higher yields and
adaptability to diverse
climates date farming is a perfect blend
of tradition and
Innovation from planting and nurturing
young Palms to harvesting sweet fruits
with shaking machines each step
showcases the dedication and skill of
farmers the global date Market continues
to expand due to the growing popularity
of this fruit and improving farming
efficiency as we conclude this episode
we hope you have gained a deeper
understanding of the intricate art of
date palm
cultivation thank you for joining us on
this fascinating Journey Don't forget to
like comment and subscribe to farm Vibes
life for more insightful documentaries
on Modern agriculture
[Music]